Why do scientists spend so much time
and effort studying fruit flies? Is it
because they're all bananas? No. Flies
are actually a lot like us. They have
hearts, brains, muscles and eyes. All
organisms evolve from a common ancestor,
and many biological parts haven't
changed much. They are very similar in
every organism. Because these parts
work well and are so useful, they tend
to stay the same. Think about a car.
There have been lots of changes in
design, but the wheels always stay the
same shape.
In broad strokes, humans divide their
cells in the same way as simple cells,
like yeast. Every organism with the
nucleus copies its DNA and separates
the copies to two new cells, using the
same molecular machines. It's faster,
easier and cheaper to study a yeast
cell than a human cell, so it makes
sense to start studying cell divisions
here. It turns out that many of the
basic principles that we have
discovered in yeast also apply to
humans, so we say that yeast is a good
model organism to study cell division.
Indeed, the lessons we learned in yeast
greatly accelerated our understanding
of cell division and how it goes wrong
in diseases like cancer.
Over the past century, scientists have
found ideal organisms to study each
specific scientific problem. Fruit
flies and roundworms have very similar
neurons to humans and are able to learn
and make complex decisions. These are
great model organisms for neurobiology.
Fish are a great model to study early
development. In the beginning, fish
look very similar to people.
So you see, we think like a fly, we
divide like yeast and our bodies start
out like fish. The underlying machinery
of life is often very similar, even in
seemingly very different organisms. But
of course, the details matter too.